we got word that yes they did see a
large mass in my abdomen learned that it
was in fact large b-cell lymphoma they
didn't really help encourage me here
that it's a very small percentage of
people that gets this kind of cancer
that you've got but it does make you ask
questions like why me my wife and I and
our church had been praying for me
through this situation we again prayed
well life could either be over very very
soon for me or perhaps God would lead us
to a place that could have some
treatment that would be successful
we had three effective ways to treat
cancer over the last hundred years and
that is surgery radiation therapy and
chemotherapy despite the best
application of these three common
modalities people in America that died
of cancer number about five hundred and
eighty thousand every year we
desperately therefore need additional
ways to treat cancer and have been
developing immunotherapy as a fourth
modality to join surgery radiation and
chemotherapy
this is dr. Steve Rosenberg he's a
cancer surgeon and he's had about the
most prestigious career a surgeon can
have but if you ask Steve Rosenberg what
his life's work is he wouldn't say
surgery for the past 40 years he's been
working on a new way of treating cancer
that can make techniques like surgery
obsolete immunotherapy doesn't use a
scalpel a radiation beam or a drug
external forces on the body rather it
attempts to modify the immune system to
fight the cancer the body's own natural
defenses that protect the body against
foreign invaders well the body
recognizes most cancers as foreign but
with not a strong enough reaction to
eliminate those cancers and the goal of
immunotherapy is to stimulate immune
responses to cause those cancers to
disappear
when I began working there was certainly
no effective immunotherapies at all
the first immunotherapy ever developed
was the administration of interleukin 2
which I started in 1976
well we treated 66 patients over the
course of many years trying to find the
best ways to stimulate the body's immune
system none of those treatments work 66
consecutive patients died until the 67th
patient a woman named Linda who I can
use her name because she's been in
newspapers around the country
Linda is now alive 30 years later she
had widespread melanoma and all
disappeared and she was only the first
of many patients now shown to respond to
immunotherapy interleukin 2 was only
effective for a small fraction of
patients but it proved dr. Rosenberg's
idea could work he and his team have
spent the last 30 years trying to
improve the treatment recently they've
had a breakthrough thanks to advances in
genetic engineering essentially they can
take your own immune cells and reprogram
them to attack cancer we can isolate the
lymphocytes from the blood the immune
Warriors of the body and then introduce
new genes into the lymphocytes to give
them a property that will recognize and
destroy the cancer
we then go on and expand themselves to
large numbers and administer them to
patients dr. Rosenberg is now testing
this approach on patients who fail to
respond to any other forms of treatment
so mr. Oaks came to us having been
through multiple chemotherapy regimens
that had not had not helped him and he
came to us with a large grapefruit-sized
mass in his abdomen and you can see it
on this cat scan right here they finally
said the chemo isn't working for you
you're not responding well to it so
there's nothing more we can do for you
however there is some new experimental
programs that are being conducted at
National Institutes of Health in
Bethesda Maryland and we're going to try
to get you in to those they took a
little bit of my blood and did a little
work on in our laboratory for about five
days put it back in and let it go to
work attacking the cancer
the treatment is pretty pretty simple
and about a month it's it's done
nice to see you walking
Hey I mean when we came back for our
first checkup is really the first
indication of how well the treatment
worked they said we see no active cancer
and my wife and I just grabbed each
other's hands and said thank you God and
thank you dr. Rosenberg it's great
relief hello sir
delighted to see you again a little
greasy here oh yeah very clean mojito
that's good so that large mass that you
had in the belly we see it continuing to
shrink it's down to about that big now
but it's dead as best we can tell the
tumor is completely has to completely
responded so we're thrilled for you're
thrilled also we've learned a lot from
you that I think are going to help a lot
of other people as well it's a very new
kind of approach as you know we
genetically manipulate the immune system
but in this situation seems to be
working working well any questions you
have for me well not right now if you
don't mind I'll forget I had cancer for
about three more months the idea later
back another trip that's what we like so
nice to mix over every day stay in touch
good thank you all right
dr. Rosenberg has had huge success with
this latest version of his treatment
it's caused regression in more than 70%
of lymphoma patients in his clinical
trials
it's an exciting moment for the field of
immunotherapy that dr. Rosenberg
pioneered and it's taken him over 40
years of single-minded pursuit to get to
this point but he's the first to point
out that any talk of a cure is still a
long way off the problem is that it
doesn't always work and especially when
it comes to solid tumors it works much
less well than it does in patients with
these blood cell tumors lymphomas so
we're working around the clock now to
apply these kinds of approaches to
patients with the common solid cancers
such as those of the colon and the
pancreas and the ovary and the prostate
until we can apply effective treatments
to all innocent people who develop
cancer there is plenty of work to be
done